we're bringing it to you from Liverpool
City Center the beating noisy heart of
the Eurovision song contest this year
and I'm on the edge of the Eurovision
Village and that's an open space right
next to the river mersey but there's a
big screen there's concerts going on
throughout the week and of course when
it comes to the competition this will be
where people can come and watch if they
haven't got the hottest ticket in town
which is a seat in the arena itself but
it's not just about the outlandish
costumes the Euro pop and the camp and
glitter this year there's something
bigger at stake and that is obvious from
just looking around at the crowds here
there are people carrying yellow and
blue balloons there are people drooped
in scarves and flags carrying those
colors the colors of Ukraine because
it's Ukraine that's at the heart of this
competition this year because last year
they won it was supposed to host but
because of the war of course they can't
take us back to Ukraine February last
year what was life like for you both
what were you doing
uh I'm working in Ukraine as Financial
director for 20 years so we have very
good life very good flat in the center
of big city yeah I was in school this is
philana and her daughter Alyssa who's
14. they're from Ukraine the eastern
part and they fled to merseyside because
of the war but since then they've been
in and out of houses and hotels and even
on the day we met them they were having
to move yet again it's their story but
it's also the story of so many
ukrainians that have arrived here in the
UK but also have been forced to leave
their homes so we wake up in the morning
and
a lot of alarm
we don't understand what to do uh just
looking in phone so first words that I
seen uh
we are bombed how it's in English we are
bombarded we can't believe that it's in
in our country our city because of our
city is very close to Russia it's first
at five o'clock four o'clock we have uh
flat on the 10th floor we see everything
it's lots of black smoke or how it's
called a lot of uh bombs it's terrible
you you just choke it and what you try
to do uh just save the life how how are
you feeling during
all of this you were at school at this
time weren't you it was totally
disappointed it was very
scared it was lots of fear don't know
what to do
yeah
just just fear she is studying very well
she has always highest level in Marx
proud mama yes yes uh she is excellent
student in the usual School in music
school excellent student so first
question when we pick up our since first
question from Hubble mom what about
school she wants to go it's bump but
Alisa wants to go to school it was funny
but not funny I know what you mean but I
imagine in that moment you don't know
what you're sort of thinking you don't
know what to take you don't know where
you're going but you eventually got to
Warsaw in Poland and how long did you
stay there for we stayed for three
months in this office and one family who
uh
ordered Visa before us in March they
give this visa to UK in March they
proposed to us uh probably you can come
try to come to England because in Poland
it's not possible to stay so we filled
some forms in May after three months we
get Visa in June we come here we came
here I mean I imagine in this time
you're just trying to keep busy you're
trying to help people to keep yourself
going but at least I know you've been
playing piano you said since you were
five years old how important was music
and playing the piano for you during
that time was it something that gave you
made you feel happy and you brought
happiness to other people too yes music
is all my life I can't imagine without a
music but as mom said we are really
helpful people so we
went lots of times to a refugee at
Center very big and there was a piano
and they played a lot for refugees in
Poland who stayed just to make them feel
better feel happier to keep this time
going easy more easy than
with music so what songs would you play
were they sad songs Happy songs
Ukrainian songs yes it was the cranium
songs or my classical more happier ones
because we need to support all of them
and make them feel happier with happy
songs and what what did people say when
they heard you playing in the refugee
centers because you would have been how
old then I was 12 there and people were
surprised but they were happy some kids
were dancing
even in music so it was pleasure for me
to play for them and amazing to see
amidst all all the things that were
happening children dancing to to music
how lovely and they said the can I uh
make video and send to my son or a
husband who is on the war he's is
because men's is still in Ukraine and go
to protect our country's soldiers yes of
course you can make videos so they make
it uh yeah people very happy because
Alyssa playing it's some for some times
it's free had for for a good mood
gave them some peace of mind and
probably some of the most important
concerts you'll ever give I imagine in
those in those situations
um Talk us through what happened when
you came to England uh we was very happy
staying eight months with a sponsor it
was old man but then he decided to stop
sponsorship and now for two months we
stay in in Travelodge Hotel from Chester
Council it's no good condition but we
try to find the Oren as a sponsor or
another place to live because I can't
find the job because we haven't
permanent address and we haven't
permanent address because I can't rent
flat because I have a job it's like yes
I I can't so if Council will give us
social house I will have job or
we asking everybody about job about or
flat because Alyssa needs to go to
school and how does that make you feel
not knowing what the future looks like
where you're going to live and your
daughter will go to school
um
we feel disappointed but we just hope
that everything will get better soon in
hotel you can't live normal life and we
need to move every week sometimes every
day they moved moved us not stay we're
not staying in one hotel we always
change hotels so with all this going on
at the same time you're living near a
city that has this enormous Music
Festival some people might think you'll
think you you would think ugh Eurovision
what's that got to do with my life right
now but actually how does it make you
feel to see Ukraine
and your your stories and your playing
Elisa so much part of of what's
Happening how does it feel to see
Ukrainian colors and Ukrainian flags and
people saying no Slava ukraines as
they're walking around how does that
make you feel
we are very happy we feel like in our
home because it's lots of people who
support in Ukraine we are very thankful
to all these people and I like when
um all this happens people get to know
more about Ukrainian tradition food and
some songs it's very very pleasure to us
and as a Great Britain a single said
that Eurovision is Ukrainian party but
in Liverpool house yeah like this Awards
too I never see been to Liverpool before
and I like the city very much because
it's very similar to harka when we lived
before
anyway because it's a student City we
saw all a lot of University and students
House Hotel students who it's like heart
of the same harkov is student City too
and I like red color everywhere I bought
this shopping bag there can you show us
what you've got yes it is
I dream about my home when I will be
home it will be first since that I put
homes with home so this is I'll just
describe it so it's a red sign with a
Liverpool Football Club logo on it so
I'm sure Jurgen clock will be happy and
and home sweet home why is it important
for you to have a message like that that
you can it's message before we come here
homes with home it's very we are very
home people so lost our home not house
home so for you home it's full of
comfort family and music and you feel
this week Liverpool's a bit like that
yes when I come to Liverpool I feel very
good not seen on the cold weather it's
not make me a bad mood I like very much
rain and this yesterday it was very
sunny day we make lots of big picture at
least I was playing
so if you like like home Liverpool
foreign
we've just popped inside because I'd
like to introduce you to someone who
actually I met in Liverpool when
Eurovision was announced as the host
City a couple of months ago and
um oh there she is hi Anna hi good to
see you how are you doing I'm good I'm
good how are you yeah very well and and
why we're speaking with Anna is because
although there are lots of individual
families like svetlanas and Alyssa's
um Anna's been helping hundreds of
ukrainians who've come here over the
past year and in your role at the big
help project
yeah yeah that's right we I work in a
big charity organization big help
project and my job is
um called Ukrainian engagement officer
and I'm actually what I'm doing is
uniting on all ukrainians and trying to
support everyone as much as I can how
many ukrainians are you helping in
Liverpool how many do you think have
come over since the war to Liverpool we
don't know exact number but we with the
help of big help project we were
arranging two big events which was
Christmas Ukrainian Christmas 7th of
January and Ukrainian East
16th of April so it was around 650
people at one event yeah so it's quite
big Community right now and you've lived
here for seven years haven't you what
brought you to Liverpool in the first
place well I met a man and then I fell
in love and then after three months I
was already made it and then I had to
move yeah live all my life like very
quickly and then move here because of
love the age-old story yeah to be honest
it's a really nice story to say for our
kids now we have a kid so and last year
you were living here and you heard about
war breaking out obviously at home talk
us through that day what what did you
wake up to when when you heard that war
had broken out I had all messages all
emails before 23rd and then I'm waking
up 24th early in the morning for some
reason I couldn't sleep longer and I
could see like so many missed calls from
my family starting from four o'clock in
the morning so I could understand that
something happened all right I was not
sure what happened but then meanwhile
why while I'm trying to it's like few
seconds I'm trying already to call them
and then I can see from other sources
messages coming World War fighting
shooting so I'm calling them so I
understand that something is going on
you must have felt absolutely sick yeah
yeah to be honest I couldn't I couldn't
eat I couldn't sleep I was very unwell
and I was saying to my husband you have
to take care of a baby because but I
couldn't do it myself my hands were
shaking and the day here in Liverpool
with you now yes now they're finally in
a safe place and I'm really happy that
they're here
um in a safe place with me we still have
quite
um bad situation in Ukraine there is
still in this very moments a quite bad
situation but very big shooting
especially
um for 9th of May it's like a Victory
Day for Russia that's why they wanted to
remind us ukrainians it's it's not a
victory for us and but people had to
continue live somehow because of your
revision it might be not a proper time
to celebrate because we have War but we
have to live to support Ukraine we have
to be strong how does it feel to be
walking around Liverpool the city that's
now your home and your family's home and
seeing Ukrainian Flags hearing Ukrainian
songs it's incredible everywhere is the
color of the Ukrainian flag it's all
blue and yellow isn't it it's
unbelievable and um we so much
appreciate this I can tell you that
especially for my
relatives on the on like example of my
family who had to move Fleet because of
the war
um I can see that it means a lot every
single flag is noticed we cannot pass
without making a picture like wow do you
see there is one more ukrainians like
another ukrainians like it means that
people support and people are with us
and that you're not forgotten even a
year yes yes we to be honest we we were
afraid that people might because it's
fun to dance to sing but we were afraid
that we might be forgotten we are not
it's absolutely wonderful to see
everywhere we see blue and yellow colors
it's it's like empowering us so much
yeah we do appreciate this and I can
tell that we will never forget this
hopefully war will finish but we will
never forget uh what is Liverpool and UK
is doing for Ukraine and for our people
and I know that music is such because we
have met before haven't we yeah and when
we met before what was it maybe six
months ago you told me that music is
such a part yeah Ukrainian culture yeah
in Ukraine we in different kinds of
situation in in good and or bad we
always singing to express our emotions
and music is the best
way of expressing our thoughts our
emotions yeah and music is empowering
and together we unite and and we are we
can deliver all kind of messages to the
world with music and songs and I'm
hoping you've got a ticket for one of
the Eurovision concerts do you yes yes I
was lucky to get one and I'm going
tomorrow with my nephew he's also
Ukrainian Refugee and I said him so we
have to get distracted a little bit from
bad news from Ukraine so we have to go
there to support Ukraine there will be a
lot of Ukrainian singers which is great
and they speak Ukrainian and English and
this is like we cannot go to Ukraine but
part of Ukraine came here it's like big
hello from Ukraine it's unbelievable
yeah we're going tomorrow and I'm sure I
will remember this forever
foreign
[Music]
I can skip excuse me hello it's all in
the name of news oh my goodness just
look at it it's wall-to-wall Eurovision
merch we've got sweatshirts emblazoned
with blue and yellow and the Eurovision
heart sign and there is what looks like
a replica of the Eurovision trophy
excuse me how much is it to buy the
Eurovision
have people been buying them yeah yeah
they've been selling quite good
so people have been spending 250 pounds
on a replica trophy of the Eurovision
trophy
and they're all
so everyone can be a champion
yeah so as you've just heard from Anna
this is a song contest that means an
awful lot to ukrainians living in the
city and we're going to get a bit of a
backstage glimpse of actually what is
happening inside the Eurovision arena
with Steve Holden who is the host of the
official Eurovision podcast Steve you
must be exhausted I am a little bit I
mean it's 17 hour days in that Arena
where it feels like 17 hour days but it
is such a wonderfully well-oiled
glamorous machine I've just come from
one of the rehearsals for semi-final two
and seeing the production and everyone
involved the scale is so epic from
production crew to the people who run
the lights to sound check to the artists
to the delegations themselves everything
has its place and its purpose and it is
just as wild and incredible as you could
imagine Eurovision would be and what is
the atmosphere like amongst the the
delegates and the people who've traveled
to take part in this competition there
must be so many nerves but is there is
also a bit of a sense of just excitement
they're all here and all together so
basically there's an area called the
delegation bubble we affectionately call
it the Dell bub right and it's where all
the dressing rooms are and there's a big
hair styling area as well and it's where
everybody comes together think about
this this is 37 countries from across
the world and they have spent months and
months perfecting their performance uh
finalizing their song there are so many
details to think about so when they come
together other countries are who they
gravitate towards because they're in the
same position so you get these really
unique friendships between countries
that or an artists who are totally
different genres but would probably
never meet apart from under the
Eurovision Arena obviously we're in
Liverpool the home of so many amazing
musicians what's it been like to be part
of this enormous contest in a city with
such an incredible Heritage Music runs
through the city and you see it in the
show I mean for example in the Grand
Final there's this segment called the
Liverpool songbook and it's returning
Eurovision artists singing famous liver
puddly and musician tracks we don't know
them yet but we can probably imagine
what they might be but some of the
artists have been down at the cavern
club which is where the Beatles started
Azerbaijan who sadly didn't go through
semi-final one their costumes were
Beatles inspired everybody all the
artists from around the world know
Liverpool for its music and it's just
it's it's basically blending what
Eurovision is with what Liverpool
already had to offer to create something
even more extravagant so yeah it's the
the liver puddly and music scene is is
running through this contest this year
it's very much
a focus on Ukraine how is that reflected
on what we're seeing inside the arena so
the whole show is as you'd imagine it's
It's a UK production with flavors of
Ukraine running all the way through we
saw this in semi-final one in the
interval act which was Rebecca Ferguson
from Liverpool doing a duet with a
Ukrainian singer who had to flee the war
and leave her country and that was shown
in the projections on the LED it was a
really Goosebump inducing moment where
we saw the flags from all across the
world come together to create this
yellow and blue heart every single
interval act has a splash of Ukraine
there's Ukrainian production crew
smattered here and there every part of
production has a Ukrainian flavor to
really make it feel like a co-production
which it is between the host broadcaster
and Ukraine's public broadcaster so I
guess on Saturday night come the final
there'll be obviously a lot of glitter
the glitz the Glam the camp that we
expect with Eurovision but also I
imagine quite a few tiers as well
amongst the crew that people have worked
on it were hearing Ukrainian music
seeing these motifs throughout I I
completely believe that I think the
amount of work that people have
dedicated to this
um the emotion is going to come out once
the the finalist is crowned on on the
Sunday I should say as well one of the
hosts is Ukrainian Julius Arnon as well
alongside Hannah waddingham and Alicia
Dixon so the Ukrainian is is front
center and behind IO I you know you
don't need to to for me to G up
Eurovision it's the most wonderful
atmosphere backstage for anyone who
thinks it's this one night of the year
just come and experience the two weeks
beforehand where everyone gets to know
each other and I always say It's the
Best Concert in the world where else
would you see all the different genres
on one stage with amazing vocals amazing
visuals it's like three hours of like
the most perfect fun and and Quality
Music I love it but you knew that
thank you so much
so much and good luck for the rest of
the week it's going to be a cracker of a
final on Saturday
I don't think it's overstating it to say
that Liverpool feels like a really
special place right now there's just an
energy that you can feel in the city
it's an energy that's driven by the
music but it's also by the people that
have come here in full dress they look
fabulous they're sounding fabulous and
they're here just to have a really good
time but underscoring all that is this
message about Ukraine and like Alyssa
has told us this feels like a place and
people who right now are united by music
how do you feel playing in these places
and being part of Eurovision yeah I feel
really proud and I'm very happy that I
can
be here to play here for people and I
know Beatles from I was in my childhood
I knew their uh some the most famous
song and they were uh my favorite like
Let It Be or yesterday so I listened
Beatles
from my childhood we are in the center
of Liverpool in Liverpool one and there
is I know a piano because I passed it on
the way here Alyssa would you play us a
little something yes of course I will a
great fantastic wish we head over now
have you got all your have you got your
home sweet home sign
so we've just found this piano outside
at one of the shops it's covered in
bright colors it's a little sort of
stand up and at least is just getting
herself comfy at the piano school and
and what are you gonna play us today
I want to play for your National
Ukrainian wonderful well I can't wait to
hear you play
[Music]
you've been listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Katarina vatati here in
Liverpool City Center uh this episode
was produced by Emma Ray Woodhouse and
the editors are Philly Beaumont and Paul
stanworth
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]